So I tell people, if you wanna eat strong food,
you wanna eat a whole food plant-based diet.
Eating foods as close to grown as possible,
where you're getting the most kick ass form of protein.
All proteins originate from plants,
most people don't know that.
And it's like the Goldilocks form of protein.
It's not too high in sulphur-containing amino acids,
they're gonna promote inflammation,
leach calcium from your bones, raise cholesterol levels,
basically burdened the dickens
out of your kidneys and your liver.
So that's one thing.
You've got the best form of protein,
as opposed to the protein that you're gonna find
in red meat, chicken, fish, any of those meats.
We now know that one of the most powerful things
that you can do to create a rock solid immune system
is to start eating a whole food plant-based diet.
And now the 10 times the number of cells that we have
of bacteria that reside in our microbiome,
we're creating a healthy microbiome
and it is gonna help us defend
against the litany of chronic Western diseases
that are out there, inflammation, all these things.
(gentle music)
Did I mention that Rip Esselstyn is here?
No, of course I didn't because I just started talking,
but I'm mentioning it now,
or I guess I did mention it a moment ago,
anyway, whatever it's true.
The Plant Strong man himself is in the house
back for his second spin on the pod.
His first being episode 336,
basically half the cannon ago, back in December of 2017.
As some of you may remember, Rip and I go way back.
As swimmers, we crossed paths
both as teens and later as college rivals.
And then decades later as plant-based athlete allies.
Rip, who was an NCAA all-American
at the University of Texas,
as well as an elite professional triathlete
was just a huge inspiration to me personally,
at the outset of my journey and has been,
and continues to be an incredible mentor,
a lighthouse, a cheerleader,
and just an absolutely wonderful friend.
For those unfamiliar, Rip is an OG in the plant-based space,
not just as this incredible athlete at age 56,
he recently broke the masters world record
in the 200 meter backstroke,
but also as an advocate, a public speaker, a podcaster,
check out the PLANTSTRONG podcast,
as well as a food entrepreneur
and New York times bestselling author.
Rip's first book, "Engine 2 Diet"
put whole food plant-based on the map
and his subsequent books, which include "Plant Strong"
"My Beef With Meat" and several others
really helps cement the benefits of this lifestyle
in mainstream consciousness.
We discuss the incredible mainstreaming of this movement.
We talk about how to rewrite your relationship with food
in the new year,
what and how to eat to perform athletically
and the power to positively change
that lives within all of us.
We also discuss is world record setting swim,
what the future of the plant-based movement looks like,
the story behind his brand new food company
titled of course, Plant Strong,
and near the end, we even get quite a bit spiritual,
a wee bit esoteric,
which is personally my favorite part of this conversation.
So please make sure you stick around
all the way to the very end.
As you'll soon discover, Rip is a good dude,
a solid dude, a loyal friend, a living Bulletproof example
of the benefits of the plant strong lifestyle.
He's a passionate man
devoted to simply helping people eat and live better.
And I really think you're gonna dig him.
To learn more about Rip, checkout plantstrong.com.
But right now, let us spin the wheel, shall we?
Because here comes the thing, me and Rip Esselstyn.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
And we're doing it?
Good to see you, my friend.
Good to see you, Rich.
We're doing this old school,
which feels appropriate.
It's audio only.
We're in the original Austin House
where old-school Rip Esselstyn
made it all happen back in the day.
So now, despite the fact that I've got this crazy studio
and multiple cameras,
it feels good to kinda go on the road
and do it the way that I used to do it back in the day
with the man himself who really has served
as many of as a mentor to me,
as a living example of this lifestyle
and I'm excited to chop it up with you.
Great to see you again, Rich
and welcome back to Austin.
Yeah, man.
I love it here.
We're here in late October, the weather is unbelievable.
I've been running around the lake
and all the pathways around here, it's so livable.
I mean, what's not to love man.
But you've been here since '82.
I came here to go to school at UT,
University of Texas and never left.
But I have seen it grow more than we ever imagined,
from 340,000 people to we're now over two million
with some of the surrounding suburbs.
And I read something recently,
we're now the 11th largest city in the United States.
It's hard to believe.
It still feels, I was just telling you,
it's still feels so livable and it feels,
I know there's been this crazy influx,
but it does feel like it has this kind of homespun,
small town feel
despite the fact that there's skyscrapers going up all
over the place and construction everywhere.
And I'm sure the traffic is way worse than it used to be.
I have heard that
it's one of the top five worst congestive cities
in the United States, because like you just said,
it's got this small town feel
and the infrastructure cannot support the demand right now
and so we're gonna have to figure out
some really smarter ways with public transportation,
subways, light, rail, all those things as we row up.
And you can feel the influx over the last year
of many more people
migrating here from Los Angeles and New York
and all the places.
Literally since 2000 Austin
and Raleigh, North Carolina
had been the two fastest growing cities in the country.
But this house that we're in,
which now serves as your office,
you bought originally when you were a firefighter,
for like pennies on the dollar,
your kids were born here.
Well, I'm almost embarrassed to say it now in 2021,
but yeah, I bought this in 2002 for $147,000.
(Rich laugh)
And it's literally worth 10 times that now,
at least.
And as I told you, when I was giving you the tour,
this thing was rat-infested, there were holes everywhere.
It was like "Alice in Wonderland"
because everything was so off level.
And the amount of work that I put into this house,
it was a lot of passion,
but this is where basically, I grew my family,
all three kids were born in the master bedroom of this house
and it's charming and we love it.
But, six years ago
it was time to move to a little bit bigger house.
This is 900 square feet.
And now it's like your man-cave office,
the cupboards and the shelves
are covered with a new food line,
the plant strong food line,
which we're gonna talk about, which is very exciting.
And it gives you some separation
between work and family, right?
Oh yeah.
As soon as I walked through that door, it's like, okay,
I'm focused in, on podcasts, work,
whatever I got to tackle in the day
related to this new kind of PLANTSTRONG empire
that we're trying to create here.
It's impressive, man.
It's a very exciting time for you.
Well, thanks a lot.
And you know exactly what I'm talking about.
I know.
So just a recap a little bit.
And I've told this story many times on the podcast,
so I don't wanna belabor it,
but from the very beginning,
you were like this lighthouse for me,
when I was trying to figure out how to find a way
of eating and living, wherein I could thrive.
I stumbled across you on Facebook and I knew your name,
we weren't acquainted in person,
but because we shared this history
of being competitive swimmers,
I knew who you were, you swam at Texas.
We'd been at a lot of the same meets over the years.
And you were posting about this plant-based diet thing
and this book that you were working on,
it must've been 2007, I think, around then.
Seven or eight , yeah.
And I just reached out to you.
And I was like, tell me what this is about.
Like, I'm super interested.
I'm at a pivotal moment in my life.
And you threw me a lifeline and became like this person
that helped me figure out, like,
because you were so much further down the path
and had been living this way for so long
and because of your accomplishments as not only a swimmer,
but a professional triathlete,
and then a firefighter,
I was like, oh, this guy like this is working for this guy.
Here's a guy that I can like cast my gaze upon and model,
how I'm gonna approach this new way of living.
And it was huge.
I mean, short of that,
I don't know that I would be sitting here right now
and whether you know it or not,
you played a huge role in that pivotal time for me,
and have continued to be a friend and a mentor
in so many ways.
So I just wanted to publicly thank you for that.
But given that you have been in this game
for such a long time,
and I think "Engine 2" came out,
the first book came out in 2009, right.
February 25th.
And you had been living
this lifestyle for many years prior to that,
it has to be unbelievably gratifying
to bear witness to the mainstream adoption
of this lifestyle.
Because the differences between when I began
and when your first book came out to what it looks like now,
I mean, it's unbelievable.
It's moving it at warp speed truly.
And the fact of the matter is it can't move fast enough,
especially given what we're facing right now
with the health of this country, with the climate crisis,
that's afoot right now, as we're going into COP26,
the big conference in Glasgow, Scotland.
When I wrote my book,
I think that maybe there were maybe 10 books
that had been written and there were all plant-based
Colin Campbell,
you had John Robbins "Diet for a New America"
yeah "Diet for a New America".
Colin Campbell, obviously with "The China Study"
and a handful of others.
And now I feel like there's a,
I mean, I'm getting people asking me to endorse their books.
Like I'm getting one a week.
You know what I'm talking about?
And it is phenomenal the amount of access
that people have to this information,
to food, to documentaries.
And my hope is that in the next 10 years or so,
we can eradicate animal agriculture from this planet.
And when I say eradicate, I don't mean eliminate completely,
but like we've done with smoking cigarettes,
eradicate, meaning let's get it down
to where less than 20% of the population is consuming this.
No small problem.
The way I think about it is on the one hand,
there has been just this explosion of interest
in this lifestyle.
I think in the early days,
there was a sense that, oh, this is a fad.
Like, this is just the latest thing it'll pass
like every other fad diets, south beach diet
and whatever, right.
Clearly history has said, otherwise,
like this is here to stay.
Every restaurant you go into as plant-based options,
the explosion of meat and dairy analog food products
is unbelievable.
Just go to any grocery store across America and quickly,
that's expanding across the world
and no longer are we in conversations with people
who say, what is plant-based or what is vegan meat?
People get it.
Let's just pause for a moment and recognize
that that's massive progress yet at the same time,
the consumption of meat globally has never been higher.
The incidence of chronic disease seems to be on the rise,
the explosion in diabetes, type two diabetes,
all of these chronic lifestyle ailments
that are rooted in diet and lifestyle
continue to metastasize.
So it's like these parallel tracks.
So on the one hand,
we can celebrate the growth of this movement,
on the other hand,
there's a despairing aspect of how I look at it, where I go,
is this making any difference?
How are we actually going?
There's other systemic things that we have to talk about
healthcare, et cetera.
We have to create environments that are conducive
to healthier lifestyles, et cetera.
But how do you think of it?
Like how do you stay optimistic and rooted in the mission?
Well, I would say that I am a,
the glass is half full, not half empty kind of guy.
And so I'm always looking for the,
I'm very optimistic and I have a lot of hope.
I mean, I have hope for humanity.
I see all the, the good that's out there,
I also see a lot of the bad and the ignorance,
but I think so much of it is just educating people.
And that's one of the things that I am,
I spent my whole career doing.
I mean, you know my path.
I should probably recap that a little bit
for people because there's a lot of new listeners
since the last time you were on the show.
I was inspired by my father
and his groundbreaking research at the Cleveland clinic,
going back to 1984.
And as a surgeon,
he kind of decided to tackle the fact that heart disease
was kind of this making of our own cause
because of what we're putting into our mouths.
And he, and I would say, Dean Ornish
have the most profound evidence-based research on the planet
showing you can actually metabolize away
these plaque formation just by changing what you eat.
And so my father has been like you said,
I was a bit of a lighthouse for you.
My father has been a huge right.
And I don't think it can be overstated,
just how radical a notion that was
at the time that he was making those proclamations.
Well, and everybody called him a clack.
They made fun of him,
but my dad has always been a true seeker
and he doesn't care what people think.
And so he's got a pretty thick skin.
And so he forged forward and lo and behold,
he started in 1984 and by 1991,
he had some pretty profound angiographic evidence.
Basically, it's like a an x-ray of the arteries
where they've put a dye in there,
but you can actually see the before and after.
And it was hugely dramatic.
And he's gone on since then to just do this again and again,
and again, and again, to show that it wasn't a fluke.
His book came out in 2007,
"Prevent and Reverse Heart Disease".
He's been written up in at least seven
of the peer reviewed medical literatures that are out there.
And he now is sits on the American college of cardiology.
He's one of the members there.
And how old is he now?
He's gonna be 88 in December.
Just a whippersnapper and as vital as ever.
Has he lost a step at all, or?
No, and he bikes every morning
and he's doing fantastically well.
Because of COVID, he's a little bit more sheltered in place
because of his age, he's taking some precautionary measures,
but what he was able to do influenced my trajectory,
my whole path in life.
And so when I went to University of Texas,
and as soon as I graduated in 1980, December 86,
I started eating this way.
As soon as I was off the athletic dining room table
with the football players of steaks and bacon and eggs
and all that stuff.
Did you do that kicking and screaming,
or you were compelled by your father's example?
People always ask that
and now I have so much respect and admiration for my father
and I have always been like one of his biggest cheerleaders.
And so kicking and screaming, not in the least,
I embraced in a big, powerful way.
And I was trying to figure it out,
of course, for the first couple of months, year.
But I also decided when I graduated
that I was not destined for 9:00 to 5:00 desk job.
And it was just made me wanna like shrivel up and die.
So I always loved competition and the thrill of it
and just the black and whiteness of it,
like, okay there's no BS.
It's just whoever crossed the finish line first,
there you go.
You're the winner.
And so I decided to try my hand and triathlons,
and I did that for a decade, right?
Swimming, biking, running.
I became the premier swimmer in the sport
for almost a decade.
And one of the top 10 in the United States
at the international distance,
not the Ironman,
that required such a whole nother mentality
and level of, I'm gonna say commitment to training.
And I already was training two to five hours a day
and I saw, the Molina's of the world
and Dave Scott and Mark Allen.
And I was like, ah, I just,
I'm gonna stick to the shorter stuff.
But you did compete at Kona
and were first out of the water.
Listen--
You might've gotten past
quickly thereafter, but you got that TV.
I competed in Kona just because you have to,
I mean, back then, I wanted to do it,
it was the granddaddy of all Ironmans.
It's the reason I got into the sport.
I saw Dave Scott in 1981 or two on wide world of sports.
And I was like, oh my God, this guy is a stallion.
I wanna do this.
And I did it. I was first out of the water.
I led until like almost a turnaround at heavy
and then got past that--
So you lead for the first half of the bike.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
And then I was passed by, that year,
it was Dave Scott, then Greg Welch, Ken Glah.
And then I came off to like 200 in like 24.
The monkey jumped on,
I shouldn't say the piano jumped on my back.
And then I finished like a thousand, like 54.
I mean, it was painful just being vertical.
I mean, I walked a mile, ran a mile.
I was like, oh my gosh.
And so my two to three hour training days
and having one or done one or 200 mile rides
followed by a 10 mile run, didn't do it.
Not the best prep for that race.
No, no, it didn't matter what I was eating.
So you were pro triathlete for 10 years?
10 Years exactly.
But then I continue to compete at a world-class level,
but not in so much the road triathlons,
but in the off-road triathlon.
So the XTERRA.
The XTERRA races
which I just gobbled up and I loved it.
And it was so different than the road triathlons
where you just kinda put your head down
and just crank that out.
Mountain biking, you've gotta be like on your game.
There's just so much going on.
I love the off-road running the trail running.
I love the loop course of the swim.
So all that.
So I did every one of the XTERRA World Championships on Maui
from 1999 to almost 2006.
And quietly plant-based the whole time
before it was a thing.
Yup. For sure.
I mean,
you had to be the only athlete.
Well, keep in mind,
and I don't know what's happened to Dave lately,
but Dave, Scott inspired me because he was 100% vegetarian
and he was so hardcore.
He'd wash his cottage cheese and things like that
to rinse off the excessive fat.
Changed his tune, lately.
Yeah.
I haven't talked to Dave about that, but--
But while he was in top form that was his approach.
And he was vocal about it at the time, as I recall.
Very vocal.
Yeah.
So in, let's see, 1997, I was like,
okay, I've been gallivanting around the globe,
long enough swimming, biking, and running,
It's time for me to hang up the Speedo,
hang up the, the Schwinn bike and the Nike shoes
and that's when I decided to try my hand at firefighting.
And I just love the fact that,
'cause triathlons, it's kind of lonely.
It's such an individual sport.
And I loved the fact that as a firefighter,
I'm part of a crew, I'm part of a team.
This is my second family.
We're going out and we are doing,
we're helping people, we're saving lives.
And we're doing that like 10 to 15 times a shift.
And I love the fact that you never knew
when that tone went off
what exactly you were gonna find when you got there?
Whether it was a fire,
whether it was somebody that had,
heaven forbid a heart attack,
whether it was a gnarly car accident, investigate smoke,
just gunshot whatever.
I would imagine
that there were more heart attack type visits
than there were houses on fire.
And that probably was, I suspect like impactful
to see people suffering up close and personal in that way.
Yeah.
Especially given kind of my knowledge and my education,
seeing all these people,
because I'd say 75 to 80% of our call volume
was responding as emergency first responders,
paramedics to this absolute, just dearth of medical calls.
So lifting assistance, calls, chest pain, heart attacks,
people whose blood sugars have gotten too low
and they're on the verge of going into a diabetic coma
and yeah, 80% were all related to,
which I will say is just the standard American diet.
And it was super sad,
'cause I felt like taking every one of them aside
and saying, "Hey, I got the answer for you here."
Well the big inflection point for you
amidst the firefighting career
was this experiment that you ran with your crew, right?
This competitive group of dudes
who are all trying to best each other in various ways,
you kind of flip the script on that and challenge everybody
to see who could lower their cholesterol the most
in a given set time period.
Exactly. Firefighters are very competitive.
And so we always have these little bets
to see who can make the most free throws
on the basketball court, in the parking lot,
who can do the most pull-ups push-ups, ping pong games.
So we had a little bit
to see who had the lowest cholesterol level.
And we found out that one of our,
my firefighting brothers had a cholesterol at 33 of 344.
And so that was really the inflection point
when we as a crew decided we would get behind
this firefighting brother and eat this way
basically in an act of solidarity to help this guy out.
And so this was in 2003 and I challenged this one guy JR
to do it, not only at the firehouse, but also at home.
So he was doing it 24/7 and then within 28 days,
his cholesterol went down to 196.
So 148 points.
Pretty dramatic.
And that's in less than a month, lost 14 pounds
sleeping, better acid reflux went away
the standard protocol.
And then the next thing this is becoming a tradition
at fire station two on the C shift,
the Austin American-Statesman does an article about us.
Then the New York Times,
the crown jewel of written media
does a front page article on the Metro section.
And then I'm getting blasted by literary agents
and publishing houses to write a book
about the escapades and the adventures
that we were having at fire station two
where we were doing something as crazy in the land of beef
as eating tofu and broccoli and steel cutouts,
and sweet potatoes and all that jazz.
Did you have a sense, like a light bulb moment
of like this is opening a door to a new path for me?
Or were you just kind of responding
to what was getting thrown at you at the time?
No, forever.
I was just responding to what was being thrown.
I tell this story, I don't know if I've told you,
but I probably got letters and emails and phone calls
from 30 different publishing houses and literary agents
soliciting me to write a book
and I never responded to any of 'em
'cause I was like, I'm like, nah, who am I?
I'm not a doctor, I'm not a life coach, I'm not a dietician.
I've got no business writing a book.
And frankly, the thought of writing a book
was very intimidating.
It's scary.
Super scary.
And at some point, and I'd say it's probably six months
after the barrage started coming in,
I just was like, thinking, you know what, well, why not?
And maybe I can reach a segment of the population
that wouldn't otherwise hear this message
from a doctor or a dietician
or your typical kind of authority figure.
And so I flew to New York
and met with all these literary agents, Richard pine,
who we've talked about
and who was behind the "The South Beach Diet"
and oh God, a litany of other books
and I decided to go with him as my literary agent.
And I spent almost two years writing the book,
doing a pilot study and all that.
I know there was some debate or discussion
like this pressure to put the word diet on the cover,
That you were resistant to.
Yeah, I didn't want to, but they insisted,
beyond there, they also insisted that in the recipe section,
you also have to have fish and chicken
as an option for people
because in 2009, when I wrote this,
they're like this is not gonna sell
for 100% vegan.
So interesting.
As you know now in subsequent additions
of the "Engine 2 Diet" we have removed all the--
So the original edition, have those in there.
For people that wanted it as an option, we had some,
but it was only a couple of the recipes,
but I felt tainted doing it.
(Rip laughs)
But the book goes on
to become a New York times bestseller,
which had to be surreal for you.
And it really does like create this opportunity
and this platform to step into this sort of call to service
in terms of like, okay, I now have this situation
in which I can really apply what I've learned
to help the many that are suffering in various ways.
And what's so beautiful about what unfolded
and we talked about this last time
is that it becomes this extraordinary family story.
Like everybody in your family participates in what was,
hence created to basically convey all of this wisdom
from your father and your mother
and your siblings, et cetera,
that has gone on to impact like millions of people.
This has been such a gift right across the board.
And I just feel so blessed and lucky that,
what I've tried to do in my life
is just always follow what I'm passionate about.
And that is kind of served me very well.
So when everybody told me,
"Oh my God, you need to get a real job.
Well, you can't just do triathlons, that's ridiculous."
I was like, listen, just like, let me figure it out.
And I did that for a decade.
And then I became a firefighter
and loved being a firefighter.
But then after I wrote this book,
the "Engine 2 Diet", and we haven't talked about this yet,
the universe kind of opened up, the clouds parted
and I got this invitation
to become a healthy eating kind of Crusader of sorts
for Whole Food Market stores.
And John Mackey, he read the book and he was like,
Rip, I want you to come on board.
I want you to educate our 100,000 team member base.
I want you to lecture to as many of our customers
as you can, go around to the UK,
Canada and the United States,
visit all of our stores and do that.
I also would love for you to be
a healthy eating immersion partner
and we will pay for our sickest team members to go and learn
from soup to nuts about this lifestyle.
And so, it's just crazy the growth trajectory
that I was thrust into in the span of writing the book,
having it hit February of 2009
and then getting this invitation
to be a healthy eating partner with Whole Foods market
in really the summer of 2009.
And then I retired from firefighting after 12 years.
Almost reluctantly.
Very, very much so.
But as John Mackey said, he's like "Rip,
if you wanna take helping people and saving lives
to a whole nother level, and I know it's not easy,
but you gotta burn the ships, burn the ships,
leave that career behind and come on board here."
And not for nothing
but I remember back in those early days,
there were certain prominent figures in the movement
who will remain on named, who were of the opinion that
it was impossible to make a living
in this kind of vein of advocacy.
Like you can write a book that's fine.
Or you can try to help people,
but extensively you're gonna need another job.
Because there was no roadmap or blueprint
for what you created.
No.
Well, I can tell you this,
that I wasn't gonna jump from firefighting
unless I had something that was a little bit more solid.
And what John Mackey offered me at Whole Foods
was more than I was making as a firefighter.
It was pretty secure.
So you ended up going on tour.
I mean, he must have done thousands of these presentations
at all these whole food markets all over the place.
Well, I went around for a decade
and I probably did close to 200 a year.
But you know what,
every time that I would get in front of that audience,
whether it was three people or 300,
I gave him everything I had.
Because they were there, they wanted to be educated
and the opportunity to help somebody out
and flip them from the standard American diet
to eating a whole food plant, strong diet,
and I've gotten so many thank yous.
And just weather, and you know this,
but when I'm doing book signings,
like thank you, you saved my life.
Thank you, you and your father saved my life.
You and your family saved my life.
And then as you know,
by John Mackey giving me this opportunity,
I also, in addition to running
these healthy eating immersion programs
that we were doing for seven days,
we then opened them up to the public.
And then it also gave me the confidence
to start doing these weekend events, which we had you too.
And so--
The plant stock
and the various retreats and immersions and--
They've morphed,
they started out as kind of farms to forks
and then we decided to call it plant stock.
And we had those weekend weekend events
and I think you came to three or four of them
over the course of (indistinct) years.
Yeah they're incredible.
They're incredible.
So back to this point of view of like traveling all over
and doing 200 of these things a year,
beyond the fact that it helped you
become this extraordinary public speaker,
'cause you were so honed in on your message,
other than like the thank you's and et cetera,
what are some of the things you learned
about how to impact people in the most meaningful way?
Like, I'm sure themes, recur,
I know when I see these people,
this is kind of the basic story that they tell,
how do you help them?
And like, what are the things that you learned
from meeting so many people
who were struggling with their health?
I think that the thing that I learned
more than anything was nobody is too far gone.
And that just about anybody can turn it around.
And Dan Buettner talks about this a ton,
but you have to create the right environment
so the healthy choice is the easy choice,
that's a big one.
And you gotta get rid of every one of the excuses
that you're gonna throw out in front of yourself,
because everybody thinks that their excuse
is better than anybody else's.
Whether it's the mother that has seven children
and is she just going nuts?
Whether it's the CEO that is on the road 150 days a year,
whether it's the guy that works off shore on an oil
and doesn't have access to food or an 18 wheel truck driver.
And I say every one of those,
because I met every one of those on my journey
and every one of them was able to figure out ways
of conquering it.
You don't know man,
I understand what you're saying Rip, that's great.
You don't understand my specific problem,
my life's too complicated for this,
thanks but no thanks.
Yep.
And so we just got to like clear the slate and say,
listen, everybody thinks that, but you can do this,
I believe in you.
I absolutely know that you can do this
and let's give it a try.
And so that's the whole thing with the 28 days
or the seven days or whatever take it for a test drive
and then you'll be the judge after that
is it something that you feel like, was it worth it?
How hard was it?
And then we know that you need support
and you need community, so you don't feel like you're alone,
especially over the, well, when I started this in 2010,
there were hardly anybody that was doing this.
So we've created some really powerful communities
at PLANTSTRONG where people can feel connected
to like-minded people.
And we have coaches that are helping answer questions,
but it's become kind of this community
where everybody helps everybody else.
And the original kind of portal for this
was enginetwo.com that's now evolved into plantstrong.com,
but it's been cool to watch over the years
how you're constantly iterating on the website
and it just becomes a more and more robust
360 degree destination for all the resources that you need
from meal planning to recipe prep
to any number of dissertations or lectures
on the why's behind all of this.
And it really is for anybody who wants to learn more
like that's all you gotta do is go to your website
and it's like all there.
Yeah, plantstrong.com we got a lot,
(Rip giggles)
and I tell you, along the way,
I've really developed such an amazing team
of mission-aligned people that work for me
from Ami Mackey, no relation to John Mackey,
Laurie Kortowich.
And then of course this whole new team that I have now.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But first I do wanna snag a quick moment
to talk about something I care a lot about,
which is the importance of nutrition.
And the thing is most people I know actually aspire
to eat better, to incorporate more whole plants, fruits,
vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily regimen.
Sadly, however, without the proper tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
And so, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everyone to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this common problem.
And the solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is, the Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands
of customizable, super delicious,
easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery.
You get access to our team of amazing nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other amazing features.
To kickstart your health intentions this new year,
we're offering you $20 off,
a one-year membership with the code Power20
throughout the entire month of January.
Again, that's promo code Power20 for $20 off
at meals.richroll.com.
All right, back to the pod.
With the new year with January upon us,
most of us are thinking about changes we'd like to make,
about sort of unlocking a better version of ourselves,
it's new year, new you time.
So I wanna explore that a little bit,
but as a kind of preface for that,
or to contextualize it all
like make the case for a plant-based diet.
Like why a plant-based diet,
why not a Mediterranean diet?
Why not a plant forward diet?
Why not a carnivore diet?
Or any number of the diets that are kind of swirling around
in people's consciousnesses
as they're trying to decide what to latch onto.
There's a lot of noise out there right now.
And I would encourage you not to go on another fool's errand
'cause there's a lot out there.
And you said, plant-based,
I'm gonna take it even a step farther than
that and say whole food plant-based
because we now know that just plant-based isn't enough.
And in 2021, there was a litany of products
that are on the shelves right now.
But as our friend, Jeff Novick would say,
they're loaded with crap.
Calorie rich and processed.
It's almost like harder,
like in the early days,
it was hard because you didn't know what to do,
there weren't a lot of resources
and there weren't a lot of products at the grocery store.
Now there's too many products
and it's very easy to delude yourself
into this idea that you're eating healthy
because they don't contain animal products,
but it's become more incumbent upon everybody
to really responsibly read these labels
and to make sure that you're not going down
some crazy process food rabbit hole,
that really is no better than the standard American diet
and the processed foods
that are kind of part and parcel of that life style.
No, I actually would, would tell you that,
so I have a podcast too.
For listeners that don't know this,
it's called the PLANTSTRONG Podcast,
and I've been doing about three years
and yesterday I interviewed Kim Williams
and I know you've had Kim on maybe once or twice.
Once, that's right
And for people that don't know,
he's the head of cardiology
at Rush University Medical Center
He also in 2015 to 16 was the president
of the American College of Cardiologists.
And he said that eating a highly processed vegan diet
is actually as unhealthy or more unhealthy
than eating a animal-based diet.
And he cited a study that was in the journal
of the American college of cardiologists in 2017.
And I came on board Whole Foods in late 2009, 2010.
And one of the things that John Mackey tasked me with doing
was doing a line of food products
called Engine 2 PLANTSTRONG
because of the 20 or 30,000 different products
around whole food shelves,
there were maybe 50 that John could eat.
'Cause he's very diligent
and hardcore.
Hardcore.
And so he loved the criteria that we had at Engine 2,
as far as being 100% whole grain.
Low sodium, or no added sodium,
no added sugars or minimal sugars, low fat,
100% plant-based.
And so he said, Rip
in conjunction with the Whole Foods team,
let's start rolling out some Engine 2 products,
we'll license this from you and let's see what we can do.
And I'm looking back now, this was so easy for me
because I was just really a passenger.
It was a licensing arrangement,
I had access to the whole Whole Foods infrastructure
from the lawyers,
the graphic designers, the food scientists.
They were doing all the travel to the manufacturers
and making sure that they passed
all the quality control tests and all these things.
And I was just basically saying, testing it
and saying, yep, I like it or, nope, that's not gonna work.
But kind of going back to your original question,
so to me, it is so easy to get swayed into this mistress
of plant-based foods, which, hey, I've had them.
They're absolutely delicious.
But if you are making these the foundation
of how you're eating that's a bit of a problem.
So then maybe define whole food plant-based.
And let's like build upon that and then talk about
why that's optimal.
So whole food plant-based
is when you're eating foods as close to grown as possible
that are minimally processed
and the one thing I left out earlier is,
we're not doing any added oils, any processed oils.
So for example, if we were to pick up one of our products,
you'd recognize just about every ingredient in there.
Jasmine rice, roasted red bell peppers, onions,
ginger, tumeric, okay.
It's not gonna be pea protein, isolates,
soy protein concentrates, coconut oil, safflower oil.
And what's your fine typically,
in all these plant-based products
that are literally in the shelves right now
is they don't have any whole food ingredients.
It's all oils, sugars, salts, and plant-based proteins.
And our friend, Colin Campbell,
he's like the whole is always better
than the sum of the parts.
And when you're eating Whole Foods,
an apple, an orange, a mango, brown rice,
you are getting this symphony of fiber, water,
phytonutrients, antioxidants, protein, carbohydrates, fats,
just the way nature intended
and that is gonna make you the best Rich Roll,
the best Rip Esselstyn, the healthiest version of ourselves.
So I'm kind of jumping ahead a little bit right now,
but so what happened
is Amazon basically acquired Whole Foods in 2017 ish.
And the world kind of shifted from underneath my feet
and the whole Whole Foods culture for the most part.
And all of a sudden they had a little different philosophy
and know that Engine 2,
it was a control brand of Whole Foods.
So Whole Foods owned it.
It was a licensing deal for you, with you.
Yes, and so in like 2019, I kinda got word
that they're just gonna be focusing in on
the Whole Foods premium brand
and the 365 everyday value brand,
but it was such an experiment
and trying to figure out and understand
what products resonated with customers
and which ones didn't.
And Engine 2, the most important thing was,
we're following their criteria, right?
No added oils the sodium's gotta be
in this one-to-one ratio,
which I can talk to you about in a sec.
And so we didn't put as much of a emphasis
on the taste factor.
And so in about 2019, when basically, they told me
that we will not be renewing the Engine 2 license
for another 10 years,
but this is a great opportunity for you
to now basically take the brand and do what you want with it
and give it the love and the attention
that it rightly deserves.
And so I'm like, all right, am I like good to go?
And am I done?
Or is this like my opportunity to like step up
and try and make this thing fly.
And the next year was one of the most challenging
and soul searching years of my life.
(both laugh)
There's great pain on your face as you say that.
Well, it's true.
Because the overwhelming nature
of what it actually means to like create
from an entrepreneurial point of view,
like create your own business in the food space.
And I had an idea how hard food was.
I had an idea, but keep in mind at Whole Foods,
I didn't get my hands too dirty.
I was above all that.
You had to have learned a ton
about how it all work though.
I mean, you couldn't have done this
when John first came to you,
like that licensing opportunity
allowed you to have an education
without having so much a scrape your knees along the way.
Absolutely.
But it's the difference between being a passenger
and being a pilot, and now I'm forced to fly the plane.
And I'm forced to find the money.
And I self-funded this thing for the first almost 15 months.
At some point I'm like, oh my gosh.
But Rich, here's the thing, it's like,
I saw this also as a challenge that I just needed to go for.
I needed to go for it because I wanted to be
everything we're talking about right now.
I wanted to be that lighthouse
for all those other brands that are out there,
that you know what?
This movement needs to continue to evolve.
And we need a brand that's kind of like the Tesla
of automobiles,
it's like the Tesla for the plant-based space.
I mean, back when we did Engine 2 at Whole Foods in 2010,
we were 10 years ahead of our time.
There was no other brand that I know of,
that was 100% plant-based.
No other.
There were some plant-based products,
but not a brand that was fully committed to this.
And so I see, I mean, I would wake up at 3:00 going,
oh my gosh, you've gotta make this work.
Do you have the stomach for this? Yes, you do.
And every day it was like another challenge,
another obstacle, like, all right, I gotta hire somebody.
Let's do a seed round.
Let's find angel investors.
I had a great lunch with John Mackey and he said,
"Rip, what you wanna do
is you wanna find people that love you,
that adore you and believe in you
and let them know exactly what you're trying to do."
And I put together,
spent a long time putting together this pitch deck,
was able to get 26 friends and family
to basically jump in,
was able to meet with a category manager at Whole Foods.
So people can't see, but I'm holding this broth up to you.
This was our organic vegetable stock.
It's actually no added sodium.
There's there's let me just take a quick peak here,
there's 20 milligrams of sodium per serving in this.
You won't find another commercialized veggie broth
that's less than probably 120,
and most of them are 500 to 700.
Huge difference.
So this is a category that is just littered with sodium,
the same thing with soups and chilies and stews.
But so I had to like earn my way back into Whole Foods.
Starting from zero.
After all of that.
After all that.
When the licensing deal ended,
obviously Whole Foods has rights to those formulations,
where they permissive
in allowing you to use the same recipes
and rebrand them as your own
Or did you have to come up with new things
out of whole cloth?
There were only a couple products
that we decided to go forward with
and I had permission to use those formulas.
So was the vegetable stock your best seller?
'Cause I would've thought the Rip's Big Bowl,
my dad loves it.
He's like I'm eating my Rip's Big Bowl.
He's not even like a plant-based guy,
but he loves his Rip's Big Bowl.
So I got this hope that okay,
this category manager wants like more.
So I got to work, hired a woman to help with food,
basically food development and kinda help create this.
I hired a guy,
you know Ken Rubin from the Rouxbe Cooking School?
Oh yeah, yeah, I think I do.
I hired him as a consultant to help
because one of the things, when I took this brand over
and I pivoted from Engine 2 to Plant Strong
and that's really important,
I want people to understand that I love Engine 2,
it's tattooed under my heart,
but it's kind of a muddy name
and you have to let the customers know what it is,
what it does and what it stands for in about half a second.
And so plant strong and decided to pivot to plant strong
as the name.
And you can see the new packaging.
I mean it's really gorgeous.
It's clear immediately what it is, what it's about.
And I mean, you know,
you can see the ingredients that are in the products.
I love the new logo.
And how many skews of the new line
are there right now.
I mean, there's lots of stuff up here on the shelves.
There are.
So there's different channels that you can go into with food
and you have to do it very strategically.
So at retail, we're starting at Whole Foods.
Whole Foods has asked for a 90 day exclusive,
that exclusive period runs out November 1st.
So starting November 1st,
we're gonna go out into other retailers like sprouts,
like Wegmans Raley's
a lot of the natural food channels.
And then when we have our sea legs,
we'll also go into some of the more conventional channels.
Like the, the targets.
What's the one down in Florida that's so--
Piggly wiggly?
Walmart?
Well, Walmart's one, but yeah.
Ralph's Font, Safeway, all that,
whatever the big ones.
The big ones.
But I got some really good advice from a guy here in Austin,
named Clayton Christopher who's just like,
got the green thumb when it comes to CPG, he said,
"Rip inch wide mile deep, inch wide mile deep in retail."
And the reason why Engine 2 was able to do that
at Whole Foods is because when you're a private label brand,
you can do that if you're just in that store.
When we were trying to go out into thousands of doors,
you gotta be more strategic.
So we took the best seller
and then we're doing line extension.
So we're doing,
on the bras we're doing are basically the same one.
We're doing the vegetable broth.
We're also doing a Shiitake mushroom broth.
We're also doing a Spanish style sofrito broth.
And lastly, we're doing a sweet corn broth.
So we got four right now that are on the shelf
and they're all like low sodium,
no added sugar unsalted oil-free.
And this is a category, like I said earlier,
it's ripe with added oils,
added sugars enough sodium to sink a ship.
And so we've done a lot of research
into making sure that these are top-notch,
they're fantastic, they taste fantastic
just to enhance and elevate all your cooking.
Whether like I made some,
just a stir fry the other day I used the sweet corn,
it was insane.
If you're just doing like steam greens,
just put some of this broth in there.
Casseroles, you name it.
It's amazing what a good broth can do for you.
And then the other thing is we used to have
an Engine 2 firehouse chili, it was a three bean chili.
And so we decided, and that sold really, really well.
So we got the firehouse chili,
we've got a creamy white bean chili,
which you can see right here.
And this has got like hatch green chilies in it.
It's got navy beans, cannellini beans, all the aromatics,
so the shallots, the onions, the garlic,
and it's got about 220 milligrams of sodium in it
per serving.
And most of your like Chili's and stews and soups
have 500 to 700.
And the Institute of Medicine has basically said
the top level for Americans
should be about 1500 milligrams, 1500.
So if you're doing like a typical,
I'll just throw out a name, Amy's Soup,
it's 750 milligrams--
Is that high?
Per serving.
There's two in a little canner Tetra Pak, right.
You've already met your upper limit just on that soup.
And so considering that we got almost a quarter of America
that is now hypertensive
or on some sort of medication for this,
this is a huge dietary need state
to meet these kinds of products.
We've also got a Indian lentil stew right here
that is just like, it's like the equivalent,
it's a kitchari
which in India is like a chicken noodle kinda soup
and it's so great for an upset stomach.
It's got black cumin in it.
Jasmine rice, red lentils, yellow lentils.
I mean, every ingredient that goes into every product
we put a ton of thought into it.
We have a Thai carrot, chickpeas stew,
that's got lemon grass, cuffer leaves, galangal, tumeric,
'cause we want that curcumin mixed with the black pepper,
the pepper in and the cumin.
It's like a one, two punch of antioxidants.
So I really think of this as food as medicine.
And you can see I'm getting pretty wound up here,
but it's like--
I like how excited you are
talking about all this stuff.
But there's like, nobody, nobody is doing this.
And so what we wanna be is, again, I'm gonna say it.
We wanna be that lighthouse
and the nexus of health meets taste.
To me there's nobody else that is doing it
like we are right now.
I imagine,
any entrepreneur is trying to build a business.
You're not only facing obstacles,
but you're compelled to have to face the possibility
of making compromises.
Like everything's a compromise, there is no ultimate,
like, yeah, you could do it this way,
but then you're gonna have to do this.
Or if you do it this way, it's gonna cost too much.
Or you can use this packaging, but this is gonna happen.
Like every decision
has all of these kinds of downstream ramifications.
I just know this from Julie's experience
with our cheese company and all of that.
So to create a line of products
that are kind of holding that apex aspirational
space of we're not compromising
on what these ingredients are.
I'm sure along the way you had people saying,
well, if you wanna do that,
yeah, that's gonna be hard, no one's done that or whatever,
is an achievement and cool.
Well that's really, and I'm glad you said that
because what a lot of companies do
is they'll just procure existing products
and then throw their label on it.
And so one of the most challenging things
that we have discovered is finding a manufacturer
that is willing to think outside the proverbial box
using our requirements
because it is--
They always tell you
we don't do it that way.
Well, yeah.
If you wanna work
with us you gotta do it this way.
So yeah, we'll have to go knock on another door.
And then the amount of time that it takes
for us to get it just right
like the Thai carrot, chickpeas stew,
we went through 28 different iterations
before we actually got it to where we were like,
this is it, home run.
And there's also, you have minimum order quantities.
So they're not gonna play unless you're willing to do,
just give you an example, 50,000 units of each one of these
and then you have to do the math and say--
You're boot strapping, this,
I mean with the payment terms and all of that,
it's gotta be suffocating.
(Rip laughs)
Fuck this.
You were telling me like, oh yeah,
I listened to the Matt Walker episode about sleep.
Like I was like, okay, this guy hasn't been sleeping,
trying to create this company.
Well, typically I don't have a hard time sleeping,
when my head hits the pillow and I'm asleep within a minute,
but yeah, I've had too many nights
more than I care to remember
where I'm waking up at 2:45, 3:00
and I'm thinking about, okay,
how are we gonna solve this?
How are we gonna do this?
But yeah, I mean, you got 50,000 minimum
a minimum order quantity.
And it's like, okay, we gotta sell this many per week.
Can we make that happen?
And the other thing I was gonna tell you
is there's different channels.
So the retail channel is one,
and it's a hugely popular channel,
but it is so bloody expensive and there's so many hurdles.
Lots of middlemen, all taking their little vig.
Lots of middlemen, you've got the supply chain,
you got distribution that you need to work out,
warehousing.
You gotta make sure that you don't have voids on shelf.
I mean, it's endless, it's absolutely endless.
The other channel that has really been lit on fire,
especially after COVID--
DTC.
DTC, right.
Direct to the consumer, Shopify, e-commerce.
And so we, about a year ago,
we started an e-commerce site for Plant Strong,
it's plantstrongfoods.com.
And this is a funny story.
So there were these two young whippersnappers out of Miami,
they were ex semi-professional soccer players,
and they'd heard the Engine 2 message
back when they were playing soccer
and so they started eating this way
and they're both like 33, 34 right now.
And they have a business where they help you build websites
and help you figure out customer acquisition
and data analytics and all that jazz.
But I didn't know that at the time,
the reason why I reached out to them
is they have a little passion project on the side
and it's called Plant Athletic.
And they basically make,
they make all this vegan wear.
I know these guys.
So Cameron and Daniel.
And so they were making these Plant Strong t-shirts
and I'm like, hey, these guys can't be making these.
I got the IP on that.
You trademarked that day one.
I did.
And so reached out to them and said,
"Hey guys, love you're doing, love everything
but you can't be doing that.
And they're like, "Hey, are you actually like Rip Esselstyn
from Engine 2?"
And they're like,
"Hey, is there any way that we can like work together
and like, blah, blah, blah.
I'm like, let's talk.
So they flew to Austin.
And again, I had no idea that they,
what their real expertise was.
And we never even talked about the t-shirts,
we just started talking about what they do
and how they can help us out so long.
And short of it is I've got these two guys in Miami
that have an amazing background in e-commerce
they are now part of the team
And like, we call them Miami Vice
that's their nickname,
'cause there are two good-looking studs, young families,
and they're responsible now for building the website,
helping us figure out how to bundle it,
how much promotions do we have to do
to keep moving the product.
And it's been a dream working with these guys.
Plus they make unbelievable cycling kits.
It's like the best stuff, I love their stuff. Good.
If you wanna rock the message when you're on your bike,
like check these guys out, Plant Athletic.
Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
And so like in that channel,
that's where we took some of the best sellers of Whole Foods
that we're not gonna do at retail,
but we're like enthusiastically doing an e-commerce
like the Rip's Big Bowl.
Yeah,
it makes perfect sense.
I mean, when I think you have all this experience
with Whole Foods, so you kind of understand that,
but the economics of that, ain't great.
And you have this incredible community of people
that you've built over many, many years,
who are passionate about you, your message.
They wanna hear from you.
They're ready to go wherever you wanna lead them.
To me, DTC just seems like the best way to go.
I mean, you should even do, maybe you're already doing this,
I don't know, but like a subscription model
where it's like every month,
you know you're gonna get your box of all the stuff,
you get that recurring revenue stream.
And it just allows you to be more connected
to this community that you've created.
Yeah, no, we're on the subscription.
That's that's definitely smart.
We got hundreds of people that are subscribing.
They need their Rip's Big Bowl.
Your father should get on that subscription.
I'll get them on it.
That's a Christmas gift, I'll but him a subscription.
I'll hook him up. I'll hook him up.
But yeah, so we took our best sellers.
So we got like the Rip's Big Bowl
and we added back the banana Walnut that was my favorite.
And we've actually taken it and we've upgraded everything.
So we're now using organic oats.
We gotta be organic, especially with the oats
and the glycinates that are out there right now.
We've totally like upped our inclusions.
So the dates are like, they're like date marshmallows.
They just kind of melt in your mouth.
The dried banana, no added oils, no added sugar,
it's just literally dried banana.
Like you ever had that banana bar anyway, it's like amazing.
And then the berries, the raisins, everything just rocks.
And then we started these granolas
because we had granola was back in the day,
but we decided to up our game and their granolas
and so we've got an all American apple pie.
We've got a classic oatmeal raisin cookie.
We've got a Berry crumble
and we have a tahini chocolate chip cookie as well.
And the thing that make these so unique
is there's no added oils, there's no added sugars
instead we're using--
In most granolas,
there's so much sugar on those things.
So we're using, we're using masqueraded dates.
So it was just the whole date.
So you have all the fiber,
all the nutrition that comes with it
and then also apples as well.
So one of the big things with the new PLANTSTRONG
is we're looking for ways always to elevate
the taste without compromising the health of it.
And you just have to get innovative
and you can make it work.
And the thing is,
and I'm going back to your original question 30 minutes ago,
all of these plant-based brands
is they're using all the tricks.
They're using all the excessive amounts of sodium.
They're using all the excessive amounts of sugar.
You look on the ingredient deck,
and I guarantee you there's three to four
different types of sugar that are in that ingredient label.
There's probably three or four different types of oil
and all these things, they're using the typical trick
and not using whole food ingredients.
Sugar, salt, and fat,
that's how you create palatability,
so if you strip that away,
you're challenged to create something
that's gonna taste good.
That's gonna appear like you were speaking earlier
about tastes, like if it doesn't taste good, man,
like you're, you're dead in the water.
So short of salt, sugar, and fat,
like coming up with a formulation
that is gonna appeal to people that has to be primary.
And where I was gonna go and spaced out, I forgot,
was most Americans pallets have becomes so hyper palletized
because of all the excess amounts of salt, sugar, and fat.
And if you read,
have you ever had David Kessler or Michael Moss
on your podcast?
No, but I know Michael Moss's book.
And so he wrote--
"Salt Sugar Fat.
David Kessler wrote "The End of Overeating".
He's the former head of the food and drug administration.
And both of them basically talk about
how these companies put salt on top of sugar on top of fat.
And then they put more salt on top of sugar on top of fat.
And they have millions of dollars to test these things,
to create the absolute peak of palatability,
to hook you and create this addictive
compulsive response with these foods.
And that creates a population of people
who have this hyper palatability issue,
where when they actually real food,
it doesn't taste good because they're so accustomed
to these processed foods that are designed to taste good,
and to trigger that addictive response but ultimately are,
what's leading us down this path towards chronic illness
and obesity and everything else.
And so we've got our work cut out for us,
but on the e-commerce side of things,
we're gonna create a master brand
where right now we've only got nine products on there.
Actually, I should say, we've got 17,
but our goal is to have 50 by the end of 2022.
So it's a store
where you can come and you can buy everything,
not everything,
but a lot of what you need to make this lifestyle work
especially if you're looking for that convenience.
And you can know that that plant strong,
when you see plant strong,
it is the good housekeeping seal of approval that this guy,
you don't have to read, you don't have to turn it over,
you don't have to look at the nutritional facts label,
look at the ingredients, this guy is good to go.
So here we are in January,
you still have to sell me on this idea of rep,
why a plant strong diet,
like why can't I have some chicken and fish?
What's wrong with some olive oil?
Like, why do I have to walk this path?
Like, what is it about this lifestyle,
this way of eating that makes it superior
that is gonna allow me to sidestep
these chronic illnesses
that have failed half my family and affected my friends.
Well, I'm gonna answer that
in a number of different ways.
The first is I'm not gonna come at it as being superior,
although it is if you're looking for optimal health,
but you see the shirt I'm wearing right now.
Eat strong food.
So I tell people, if you wanna eat strong food,
this is direction you wanna go in.
You wanna eat a whole food plant-based diet
eating foods, as close to growing as possible,
where you know you're getting the most kick-ass
form of protein.
All proteins originate from plants.
Most people don't know that.
And it's like the Goldilocks form of protein.
It's not too high in the sulfur-containing amino acids
that are gonna promote inflammation,
leech calcium from your bones, raise cholesterol levels,
basically burdened the dickens
out of your kidneys and your liver, right?
So that's one thing.
You got the best form of protein,
as opposed to the protein that you're gonna find
in red meat, chicken, fish, any of those meats.
Dr. McDougall, he loves to say that
anything that flaps a wing, wiggles a fin
paws a hoof or closes a clam,
inside there, you've got these substances,
these insidious substances like cholesterol,
like saturated fat, like problematic animal protein.
You just can't get away from it.
Whereas you look at the strong foods, the whole plants,
you got Goldilocks protein,
you got the number one form of carbohydrates
that are gonna fuel our 37 trillion cells.
You and I are both comprised of about 37 trillion cells.
And what fuels us is it's glucose, it's sugar, right?
Unless we're trying to do something
like go on the keto or the carnivore
and now we're trying to fuel ourselves
with ketones and basically fat,
which I don't recommend to anyone.
And then when it comes to fat,
you're getting the essential polyunsaturated fatty acids
that we so as human beings, we so desperately need.
And the reason why it's called essential
is because our bodies cannot manufacture these on their own,
we have to get them from food.
And most Americans, Rich,
are getting 35 to 50% of their calories from fat
and it's the wrong kind of fat.
It's the fat that's coming,
it's saturated fat that you're gonna find in chicken
in eggs, in red meat, all those kinds of things.
So you're avoiding all those things.
But the thing that I'm gonna like harp on right now,
and this is pretty new.
And if you ever had, Will Bulsiewicz on your show?
Yes.
Okay.
It's the microbiome, right?
We now know that one of the most powerful
things that you can do to create a rock solid immune system
to help like mitigate all those cravings for bad food
is to start eating a whole food plant-based diet.
And now the 10 times,
the number of cells that we have of bacteria
that reside in our microbiome,
we're creating a healthy microbiome.
And it is gonna help us defend
against the litany of chronic Western diseases
that are out there, inflammation, all these things.
And I'm Kim Williams, who I was interviewing yesterday,
as far as like, why should he plant strong?
So Kim, and again, he's on my mind
'cause I interviewed him yesterday,
but I asked him, I said, "What are you doing Kim,
to motivate your patients after they've had a stent
or a bypass or a procedure?"
And he said "You know Rip,
I found this motivational interviewing technique.
I discovered it in January of 2019
and it works almost every time, like a charm."
I'm like, "Tell me, I wanna know."
And he said, "Okay.
So I walk into the room
and I let him know that I am Kim Williams,
I'm the head of cardiology here.
If you don't mind,
I'd like to ask you a couple of really silly questions.
First question is,
what's your understanding of why you ended up here
and needed a stent or bypass?"
And he said, they'll say, "Well, I had a blocked artery
that's my understanding."
And he'll say, "Right.
And what was it clogged with?"
And he said, 90% of the time, we'll say plaque.
And he'll say, "Exactly."
And do you know what was that plaque made of?
And he said, most of the time they'll say,
"Cholesterol and fat."
And then he'll say, "Well, where did that come from?"
And they'll say, "Well, I ate it."
And then they'll say,
"And what saturated fat have that cholesterol?
And if you wanna continue to eat that way,
know that I will be here, Rush University Medical Center,
we'll be here with our 51 cardiologists
to play surgical whack-a-mole
and we'll put in another stent, we'll do another bypass.
Or if you decide you wanna eat plant-based
you probably never have to see us again."
But he said just the fact of getting
that coming out of their mouth and connecting the dots
is super powerful.
I think it's cool that he,
what I hear on that is he's giving the patient agency,
rather, were you still like the doctor coming in and saying,
this is the way it is, and this is why you're here
and here's what you need to do and then goodbye,
as opposed to a line of questions
that then compels the patient to think
it gives them sort of power over those decisions
and leads them towards the conclusion
that ultimately he wants them to arrive at.
Exactly, and now they're a participant
as opposed to being lectured at.
Exactly.
Where they're just gonna tune out
and go do whatever they're gonna do.
Yep.
I mean, frankly for health reasons, whole food plant-based,
that's like the pinnacle that's where you wanna be headed.
But I mean, as we started,
I think said in the very beginning of this
we got this climate crisis, that's a foot right now.
And from everything that I've read
and we're already over 400 parts per million
when it comes to the amount of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere, which is, I guess, very, very scary
by 2050 mid-century, I think the goal of this COP26 meeting
is to become net zero and to keep that 1.5 degrees Celsius
from getting up that high.
And I read like,
what are they asking countries to come to the table with
as far as what they can do to kinda reach these goals
of being net zero by mid-century
and making sure we don't increase our temperature
by 1.5 degrees Celsius.
And these are the four things they've asked,
accelerate the phase out of coal per tail deforestation.
Speed up the switch to electric vehicles
and encourage investment in renewable energies.
Nowhere there do I see
anything about eating a plant-based diet?
That's insane because by all accounts,
every acclaimed climate scientist
understands that there's no way
we can achieve those benchmarks
without reducing the global demand for meat.
And when you talk about deforestation,
we're deforesting to clear land
for grazing and raising crops for animal feed.
There's just no way around achieving our aims
unless we adopt a more plant centric diet
and get off the teat of our animal food addiction.
And you know Khaled bin Alwaleed,
one of the Saudi Arabian princes,
he has basically said that it is his goal in our lifetime
to relegate animal agriculture,
to the bin of basically history.
He's created this whole venture fund
and has placed large investments
in all of these companies and startups
that are moving our world in that direction.
(indistinct) Meat, all that stuff.
But here's where I wanna take this to the next level
and that is almost all of us have seen Cowspiracy,
where Kip Andersen talks about how he found this report
by the World WASH Institute, that's part of the World Bank
called Livestock's Long Shadow.
And in it, they talk about how between the supply chain
and in the life cycle of the close to 80 billion animals
that we grow and then basically slaughter
and then eat annually,
51% of global greenhouse gases
are caused because of that, 51.
They also talk the number that I see floating around a lot
is 14 and 15%.
It's the same as all forms of transportation combined.
But I just heard six months ago.
Have you ever heard of a guy named Sailesh Rao?
Yes. I had him on the show.
Oh, okay, there you go.
So Stanford, the director of climate healers,
basically he has new research showing that it's not 14%
animal agriculture, it's not 14%, it's not 51%, it's 87%
of global greenhouse gas emissions
are caused by everything related to animal agriculture.
How did he come up with that number?
I'll send you the paper.
But I think again, it's between the supply chain,
all the trucks, all the deforestation
all the water resources, you name it.
And so this is why I look at this and the goals
of this meeting in Glasgow in a couple of weeks,
and that's not even on there,
we've gotta figure out a way to get this front and center.
I mean, Billie Eilish,
I mean the number of celebrity people
that are getting behind this message, Phoenix.
Joaquin Phoenix.
I think it's his birthday today.
Happy birthday Joaquin.
Have you ever had him
on the show?
No, I'd love to.
He's a reclusive one that guy.
So frankly,
we are in a bit of a pickle right now,
and we need everybody that makes sense
screaming from the mountain tops,
hey, planet earth, you gotta plant-based like
as fast as humanly possible.
And this is why I am a fan of everything that's going on
in this plant-based food industry.
If we can get people to eat this way, fantastic,
because at least we'll have a mother earth
in a hundred years or so, right.
This PLANTSTRONG, this is a whole nother kind of level
of plant-based it's the varsity program.
And it's probably not for everyone,
but anybody that wants to take their health
to the next level, this is it.
But I am such a fan of what's going on right now.
I know you were here meeting with a company called Daring,
the innovation that's going into this industry,
the rate at which it's growing,
a couple facts, 2014 global data,
which is this research firm did this research
and they showed that 1% of US American citizens
identified as vegan, 1%.
2017, three years later,
6% of US citizens now identified as vegan.
That's an increase of 600%.
And imagine what it is now in 2021,
I bet you, we're getting close to that tipping point of 10%.
And I see the laundry detergent
now that's claiming plant-based.
I mean, there's also
a lot of like greenwashing out there.
It's like, oh, we need to be on board.
This is like the thing that we need to be associated with.
How can we do that?
Well, we'll change that the in color
on our labeling to green, there's a lot of that,
but that just means that this is in the culture
and in the sensibility
and people understand that they need to align
with the plant-based sensibility in consumer products
if you wanna be competitive in our capitalist society,
which is all told a good thing.
Yes, the plant strong line,
like where you're coming from is the varsity program.
And it's important to remind people like,
look, I'm like a flick the switch guy.
Like I'm gonna cross that line and not look back.
I know you're the same way.
Most people Rip, I got news for you,
they don't really function that way.
I wish they did, they don't.
We gotta ease people into this.
And any changes that you can make
in a positive direction are awesome.
I mean, you mentioned Dr. B earlier
Will Bulsiewicz.
When I got interested in this,
it was very much from a personal health perspective
and perhaps a vanity perspective.
I was fat, I felt like shit.
I saw those before and after angiograms
that are in your dad's book, it's profound.
You see the reversal.
You're like, wow, just eat plants
and you can go from A, to B on this.
Like that is unbelievable.
And it got like branded into my brain.
But now we have all these other on-ramps for people
that are interested in making changes.
So perhaps you're not worried about heart disease
or perhaps you're not worried about diabetes.
A lot of people are,
that's a good reason to consider this lifestyle.
But maybe you have an autoimmune disease
or you have some kind of inflammation
that you can't get on top of Dr. Will Bulsiewicz
will tell you that the best way to begin to address that
is by increasing the diversity of plants in your diet.
Like, that's this whole thing, it's about the diversity.
He wants you to get 30 different
every week.
I know, right?
Like that's a challenge, you want a challenge?
Take that challenge on.
That's not so hard,
it's not telling you, you can't do X, Y, or Z,
and it's not focused on the things you're not eating,
it's about like, how can you get
30 different types of plants down your noggin
every single day?
Like, you know what I mean?
And I love that.
And now we have this environmental issue,
when I began this journey, I don't know about you,
I wasn't thinking about that at all.
Now I think about that all the time.
It's so powerful.
And I think everybody is thinking more deeply
about how to live more sustainably
and more gently on this planet.
And when you look at the numbers
and you kind of really sit
with everything that you just shared, Rip,
you can't get around the fact that pivoting towards
a plant-based world is really
a crucial aspect of this solution.
Oh, it's mandatory.
It's mandatory.
And things have changed so much for me
over the last 10 years.
Like you, I've got kids now, I've got three kids
and you can't help but think about their future,
and then their kids,
and the fact that these guys are talking
about climate change and we had last February, Rich,
we had, you probably heard about,
we had snowmageddonhere in Austin, Texas.
I've been here 30, almost 40 years, 39 years,
we had snow for three days.
We had freezing temperatures for almost four or five days.
We had the electricity off on our house, we had no water.
It was downright frightening.
And most people don't have four wheel drive vehicles.
I had a friend, you know Rick Kent,
who was in his apartment
and I basically took my life in my hands,
in my little car and got him and he came and stayed with us
'cause he was in his apartment that was 37 degrees
for three days.
And I was like, dude, you're gonna die.
Things like that.
And then of course the fact that
we're having the hottest year ever.
And it seems like every year is the hottest year ever.
It's staring us right in the face and it is downright scary.
How old are your kids now?
Thank you for asking.
I got married late in life.
I was almost 44 when I got--
You had you Peter pan thing
going on for awhile.
I big time, big time.
And I married a wonderful, wonderful woman.
But I got a seven year old daughter named Hope
and Hope is an absolute firecracker.
And then I've got a 12 year old daughter named Sophie
and Sophie is like an old soul.
She is so like, cool, calm collect, she keeps us in check.
It's just crazy.
And then I've got a son Cole who's, who's 14,
much more like me
and he's like all about athletics and swimming
and sports right now.
Have you had any challenges with them
deciding like, hey,
'cause look, when you're a parent nothing you do is cool.
I don't know what your experience has been,
but like my kids,
they're like trying to figure out
how to define themselves in opposition.
So they're like,
yeah, I know you do that stupid thing over there,
but I'm going over here
'cause they're trying to figure out who they are
And part of that is great and natural,
they have to experience life on their own terms
and push the envelope and figure out
where the guardrails are and all of that.
When it comes to the foods that they're eating,
I mean, my kids have never had meat,
but they go off and like, do whatever they're gonna do.
And all you can do is like, this is the way we eat here.
Educate them about the how's and the why's behind it.
And then on some level,
I mean, my kids are older than yours,
you have to let go a little bit.
So you're just on the precipice of like the hormone storm,
how to descend upon these kids.
It'll be interesting to see how that plays out.
But are they like all on board with you right now
on all this stuff?
Rich, I couldn't be luckier.
They are so on bored.
And I think it's kind of like how I was with my father.
I was just like,
I just admired him and respected him so much.
And just seeing him put his shoulder to the grindstone
and do things that people said were impossible to do.
And I think my kids they've been,
and they've seen me talk at Whole Foods, they see what I do.
They they see all the Plant Strong Engine 2 products
littered throughout the house.
They see me doing the podcast.
They see how hard daddy works.
And so I haven't gotten
there's been no pushback with the food.
And actually, if anything,
they wear it with a kind of badge of honor,
like really proudly.
But--
That's cool.
We've got the, NadaMoo ice cream in the freezer
and they're going after that and the Mary's Gone Crackers
and stuff like that.
I mean, and they'll go to birthday parties
and they'll have the birthday cake
and we typically will bring our own vision cupcakes
or stuff like that.
But no real pushback.
And the thing is, Rich,
I don't know about you with your kids,
I try and shower them with as much love as I can.
And my daughters, I heard a quote from a guy,
his name's actually Dale Hayden,
he was a triathlon buddy of mine,
but he told me this in like 1988 and I never forgot it.
And he said, "You know Rip, a woman's beauty
is her father's love for her shining through her eyes."
And I was like--
Oh, that's awesome.
Oh my God, and I was like,
I mean, you can see I'm getting goosebumps right now.
And I was like, when I have children,
if I have any daughters,
I am gonna let them know how much I absolutely adore them,
how much I love them.
And I don't wanna ever clip their wings.
I want them to continue to just be bright burning suns.
And so I say, I love you.
We do that in our family so much.
And when I was growing up, we didn't do that a lot.
And so I, we really err on doing that,
being affectionate, holding hands, all that stuff.
With my son, Cole it's a little different relationship
in that, I'm a little harder on him
and my wife has to reign me in a lot and say,
"Hey, you're being much harder on Cole
than you ever have.
But dads and daughters,
it's like like the D of softie, I know what that's like.
But anyway, having kids has been
just one of the greatest experience of my life.
It's one of the hardest things.
It's one of the most gratifying things.
It's just incredible.
And to kind of connect all this a little bit
'cause you and I,
and I think a lot of people on your podcast,
we don't shy away from doing hard things.
And there's a certain joy and gratitude
that comes with tackling hard things
and conquering it and then moving on.
And I'll just say it again.
I've never experienced anything as challenging,
as hard as, as this right here, right.
Is launching this food line.
You're pointing like you don't mean parenting,
you mean like launching the food.
Now I'm talking about the food line
and parenting is right there, it's the same.
And also making sure that the relationship with my wife
is solid 'cause it's so easy to get off base.
And when I was traveling a hundred days a year and all that.
I don't know how you did that.
Looking back, I can't believe it either.
So this, if I can conquer this,
if I can, over the next 10 years
be a lighthouse for other brands
and really further the whole,
whole food plant-based movement,
not the plant-based movement,
but the whole food plant-based movement
then I will have been successful.
And I just gotta be authentic to what I started back in 2009
and what this brand stands for.
We have spoken for over an hour and a half
and not yet have we brought up the fact
that you set a world record in the 200 meter backstroke
at age 56.
And that was--
55 to 59.
And that was really stupid of me.
Why?
'Cause I should have done it
when I was 55.
Oh, right.
'Cause you're at the bottom of your age group.
What could you have done at 55?
Exactly.
I know.
You went like 220?
220.8.
220.
Well, actually,
so, talking about hard things.
So some guy challenged me, he said,
"Hey, Rip you know there's a meet at ASC,
the pool that you swam at,
and it's a long course meet so you get a world record,
why don't you go for it?"
And it was two weeks away.
And I had to swim in a long course meter pool
in a couple of years,
but I figured, okay, I'll give it a shot.
And do you wanna hear the story?
I do.
And I think, the reason I bring it up other than like,
I wanna celebrate the fact that you broke a world record
because it's totally bad-ass,
but I think in the back of people's minds,
it's important for people to connect the dots
on your athletic experience
because when you talk about all things plant-based
you think about like,
well, how am I gonna be able to be robust?
How am I gonna be able to go out and like be active
and do the kind of things that I like to do,
is a plant-based diet going to sustain me?
And you at age 56, breaking the world record
in the 200 meter backstroke, it's fucking cool, man.
So I do wanna hear this story.
Yeah. So (sighs),
the record was a 222.7.
Who held it?
I can't remember his name.
Somebody like Rick Carey
or something.
No, no, come on.
I don't think Rick spending a pool since--
(indistinct)
No.
Krayzelburg.
No, he's not that old.
No, he's not.
He's not old enough.
He's not.
So I went and I missed it by over 2 1/2 seconds.
So I went like a two, almost 224.9, 225 low.
And I can remember,
I knew I had to take it out in about a 109, 110.
I was out in a 111, came back into like a 13
and I had somebody on the deck holding up his fingers,
like what I was, 'cause I figured I'd be an eight, nine.
Well, he held up both hands signaling
that I was like a 110 or above.
And I can tell you, Rich that second 100 meters,
my stomach got tied up in knots,
my legs felt like there was cement being poured into them.
I was breathing like a freight train.
And I was like, why am I doing this to myself?
What do I gotta prove to anybody?
So I finished and I didn't get it.
And I'm like, okay, I'm done.
Whoever set that record, good for you, you stud.
And then that night I was going to bed and I'm like,
I got this nine, you know?
I'm like, yeah, God dang it.
Competitive firefighter Rearing its head.
Oh, I'm like, okay. Rip, think about it,
why didn't you get it?
Well, you haven't been in a 50 meter pool,
as a swimmer it's almost a different animal completely.
I mean law course, I mean forget about it.
You can't get away with nothing.
There's no where to run, there's nowhere to hide.
And so I did my homework and I found another meet
that was gonna be in at the Dad's Club in Houston, Texas.
Wow that's three way back
In three weeks.
The Dad's Club, that's still a thing?
It's still a thing
and the pool is like three feet deep.
But it was the only meat in the next three weeks
that I could drive to
and then we were going on vacation for a month.
So I went to a different master's program
'cause I knew I needed to swim in long course.
So I went to the ASC pool.
I trained for like two and a half weeks there.
I woke up at 5:30, had the PTSD going.
Like you're an average masters swimmer.
So you were like going to work out all that.
It wasn't like, oh, I'm--
I'm going
five days a week yards,
but again, meters.
I did all kinds of race, pay stuff.
I made sure my stroke was a little bit longer.
I saved my legs for the second 50.
And so I got to that meet in the Dad's Club
and I felt comfortable in meters again.
And again, I had somebody on the deck, hold up your fingers,
let me know ,I'm out in the 108, 109.
I see two hands again.
110.
Actually it was a 111,
but she couldn't do anything.
And so I'm like, okay, 110.
Oh my God, I gotta bring it back into 112.
That's what I'm thinking in my head.
You're essentially even splitting--
Even splitting.
At any age that's very difficult.
And so I started like,
all right, let's dig in, let's do it.
And my stomach didn't go up in knots.
My legs felt good, my turnover was solid.
The last 50, I like cranked it up.
And I was like, and I touched the wall 221.8.
So I got the record by nine tenths.
And I was out in a 111.5 and I came back in a 110 something.
So I negative split.
Negative split.
Negative split it.
For people that don't fully understand swimming,
I mean that now that's extremely difficult
and almost never happens.
And so then I went on vacation for a month
to Wisconsin, this little rustic cabin on the lake to unwind
and I swam every day for 20 minutes
and I decided that I would just do some interval stuff
in the lake where I go a minute hard, a minute easy.
And I came back here and I got an invitation
from this woman that ran that meet at the Dad's Club,
she was running a meet at Texas A&M.
This is an indoor 50 meter pool.
It was like the districts of masters swimming.
And as opposed to at the Dad's Club
in the 200 meter backstroke heat,
I was next to an 88 year old woman and a 40 year old guy,
there were three of us in the heat.
So I lapped the 88 year old woman or whatever.
God bless her.
God bless her is right.
But at this, there were nine heats of men.
and I was in the last heat next to a 22 year old dude
who was in at a 219 and I was in at 221.
So we went out together and I was out in a 109,
like flat and I felt the month on vacation,
the second hundred.
But I mean, toy were swimming 20 Minutes a day.
But I went at 220.8.
So I lowered my old record by a second
and it was all because of this guy that was next to me.
I beat him by a 10th and it hurts so bad,
but--
He must've been bumped.
He'd walked over and he's like this dude.
I think he was a little bit dismayed for sure.
All that Goldilocks protein.
Thank you Goldilocks protein.
And now I got people asking me
'cause I'm gonna be 59 in four months,
"Hey, you're gonna go for the 60 to 60, 64.
And I probably will have to, but.
What's the record in the next age group.
Do you know?
I think it's a 226. It's pretty soft.
Soft record sitting there with your name on it.
Kinda cherry pick it.
But you never went to like masters worlds
or masters, 'cause there's bigger meets.
The worlds is always in some really cool city
halfway across the world.
I would do it,
but now that I'm married, I've got three kids,
it's like how much time do I wanna spend doing that?
And so the fact that I could do everything that I did
and it was all driving distance.
So it just was a Saturday.
Like the A&M meet ,I woke up at six I was home by noon.
I think it's powerful because it demonstrates
not only can you still perform at your age
at a very high level, the ripple effects of that.
A lot of news pick that up.
It got reported on and it becomes this narrative
of like, not only can you be a competitive athlete
as a plant-based person,
but the longevity piece also I think is really important.
And then truth be told Rich,
I got that record in the first one in June,
the second one, I think in August of 2019.
And I knew that the game changers was coming out.
It'd be good for the movie and all that.
Because I was one of the executive producers
and because I had a small little piece in it.
I wanted to like, let people know
you can still be in your 50s, 40s, 50s, 60s
and like, be like at the top of the world.
And not for nothing. Like I still got.
In case you were questioning, I still got some juice.
And I can remember,
I think when I was on your podcast for the first time,
and I told you that I was gonna go for a world record
and you said, I can't remember what you said exactly,
I'll have to go back and look, but you were like,
"Dude, you can do this."
About time.
You got this.
And anyway, so yeah, about time.
Yeah, it was great.
I think about this a lot too,
I don't have the time to train
the way that I was training
when I was doing all those ultra distance things.
I wake up and I think what's the best use
of the limited amount of time and energy that I have.
Like how can I use what I have
to impact the most number of people
in the most meaningful way.
And usually that means doing exactly
what we're doing right now,
or working on a book or going and speaking somewhere.
Every once in a while,
there is merit and value in investing that time and energy
into something athletic,
because it demonstrates that vitality.
You can talk about all this stuff, all you want,
but ultimately, as you know
and as game changers was so important in advancing,
like people watch what people do.
And when people go out in the world
and they execute at a high level
that is gonna lodge into their brains
and in their consciousness
in a way that's much more important
than the latest study that you retweet
or whatever else it is.
It's like, that's how people learn.
It's not necessarily like you were talking about,
it's about education, yes it is.
But how do people learn?
Like what's the best way to impact people
in a way that's gonna move the needle?
And I think storytelling is a huge piece
and doing something hard.
Like when you go out and you do something hard
and you succeed, that is a powerful story
that people don't forget.
I look at so many of the people
that you've had on your podcast from Collin--
O'Brady.
To Jesse Jesse Itzler,
there's just doing all these crazy, crazy feats.
And I feel like I'm at a point in my life now
where I'm excited for them, but I can't wrap my,
I personally can't wrap my head around it.
Climbing Everest or doing the last man standing event,
doing this loop.
Do you know Harvey Lewis.
Dude,
I'm trying to have him on my podcast.
I just got a date to schedule him on
to have him come on.
so did he win that thing?
Not only won it, he did more,
they call it yard or is it,
yeah, I think it's a yard.
A loop, like a four mile loop,
I think they call it a yard
and he did more than anybody ever has.
Was it three days or three nights?
Something like that.
I don't know the exact stats, but he just ran an insane
and he was going ultra after ultra, after ultra
leading up to this, it's not like, he hadn't done anything.
Like he just did a couple huge races earlier this year.
But here's the thing that's my--
Plant-based, we should point out.
I mean, that's the reasons we're bringing them up.
But one of the things that's mind blowing to me
is that I think these guys were up
pushing each other for three or four days in a row.
And Matthew Walker is gonna have a stroke
when he thinks about that.
'Cause guys don't sleep at all.
No, but I mean, I think in the podcast with you,
he said, how you go five, six days,
you're looking at death and permanent, disability mentally.
I mean, whoa.
Right.
There is a moment in your life where you want a stretch,
prove what you're capable of, do the thing.
And then there's a twilight on that.
Like, you've proved everything
that you need to prove to yourself.
You've established your bonafide days
as a virulent athlete who can perform at a high level
on a plant-based diet.
Do you really need to invest more time and energy
to double down on a case you've already made?
That's really the question.
Would you ever entertain doing another ultra man
or something like that
or does it make you too sick to the stomach?
I love it like left to my own devices, I love to train,
if I had nothing to do, I would just,
Like yesterday I ran and I went over to Barton Springs
and I swear, I was like, what else can I do today?
Can I get on one of those boats out there and paddle around?
Like I just enjoy it.
So I don't think of it as burdensome,
but to place that kind of rigorous
training schedule template
on top of my life right now, it would be impossible.
And I don't feel like there's that much more for me to say
in that space that I haven't already said to myself
that would justify that amount of time commitment
to do that thing.
That's kind of how I look at it.
But I like doing hard things and I wanna stay challenged
by tackling things that scare me from time to time.
I think that's important as well.
I look at, like Scott Jurek for example,
who got the Appalachian trail record
and then just recently he went forward again,
had an issue with his knee and had to drop out,
but I'm like, wow, Scott,
'cause I read his book "North"
and he basically, by the end of that,
he was mincemeat ,he was absolute mincemeat.
I mean, he'd lost so much weight.
He looked like another day that might've done a in him.
I mean, it was unbelievable and he achieved.
Unbelievable.
But again, I applaud people that are getting out there,
getting after it pushing the boundaries.
I mean, wow.
And now there's a whole new generation of people,
they can do it for us.
We can be on the sidelines cheering them on.
So wait, so you're 55,
you just turned.
I just turned 55.
How's that feel it feel?
I mean, I feel good, I feel fine.
I think when I turned 50,
I didn't think twice about it, then when I turned 52,
like the white hair started coming in really fast
and I was like, oh, that's interesting.
Like this is different.
55, you're rounding towards 60.
So I think that one landed a little bit harder.
I don't know how it's been for you,
but well, I no spring chicken anymore,
but I get out and I get after it and I'm able to,
I wake up grateful every day that I feel good in my body
and I can go out and be active.
I got some back stuff and I'm not immune
from little things here and there
that are bugging me that didn't used to
One of the things I've learned
is nobody likes to really hear anybody complain
about aches and pains that they have.
It's kind of like a big yawner.
And you try and empathize with them.
But I had something happen to me
and it was one of the reasons why
last year was one of the most difficult in my life.
In addition to trying to launch this PLANTSTRONG brand,
and that is, I was on a mountain bike ride behind my house
and--
Try to forgot--
And I've been mountain biking for 30 years
and I'm like, Gumby, I fall and I'm like, okay,
took this fall and, oh my gosh.
I heard a snap, I got nauseous in my stomach.
I tried standing up, I fell back down on the ground.
I basically snapped my fibula.
And so I broke my ankle.
I had to be carried, carried out from the Greenbelt.
And I had surgery about a week later
and I had a plate and eight pins put on.
I didn't walk for almost five months.
Hobbling around on crutches or a little scooter.
It gave me such respect and empathy
for people that are handicapped,
that people have any issues with being ambulatory,
things like that.
I'm looking now for the handicap stalls,
the handicap ramp ways all that stuff.
That's rough man, five months.
I didn't realize--
Oh five months.
Five months.
And I still have some issues
and I wanna have the plate in the pins taken out
because it just never feels quite right.
And I haven't really, I mean, I run,
but not like I used to.
You out on the bike at all though
or are you just hitting the pool?
No, no.
You're done.
No I'm biking, I got back on that horse
and it was scary the first week or so.
And the trails here,
have you run the Greenbelt at all?
Well, there's a lot of like corollary trails
that run off the main Greenbelt
and that's where the excitement is.
More like single track stuff.
Single track, ledges, roots rocks.
I mean, it it's gnarly stuff, you have to have some skills.
And so getting back on the bike was,
the first week was rough and then I got back,
but I'm always now a little bit more tentative
than I was before.
It's unavoidable, man.
But I'm glad you're back in one piece.
It feels good to be back.
And I just now just walking, I'm like, oh, thank you.
I'm so grateful.
But it made me think of our friend Paul de Gelder
and what that man went through and his spirit
and his tenacity.
That's unbelievable.
The manner in which he carries himself
with such gratitude and poise is remarkable.
I just saw him a couple of weeks ago.
I mean for people that don't know,
victim of a bull shark attack in Sydney Harbor
lost half his leg and half of one arm,
but has become this incredible ambassador
for shark preservation, for ecological responsibility.
And so many things, it's such a powerful voice.
And he goes into the gym and he kills it.
And just no excuses, no woe is me whatsoever.
Just like walks the talk.
Big time.
And he's now like the host of "Shark Week"
on Discovery Channel.
It's like a full-time job.
They got them flying all over the place all the time.
And doing stuff with like Mike Tyson.
He gets to see people like Mike Tyson and Will Smith
basically poop their pants.
I know.
It's hilarious, man.
We're not gonna end this without leaving people
with some takeaways
who are thinking about
getting on the plant strong bandwagon.
What do I do first?
How do I make this switch?
What do I watch out for?
Help me, Rip.
Help me help them.
Well, the first thing I would recommend
is you gotta start somewhere
and I would just go to plantstrong.com
and I would take the seven day challenge.
Literally anybody can do anything for seven days.
So take this challenge and don't think of it as a challenge
if you have a lot of challenges in your life,
think of it as an adventure and healthy eating.
And what I always tell people is just find foods
that you love and like do steel cut oats for breakfast,
with a slice banana, maybe a little bit of oat milk on top.
Do the commercialized, Rip's Big Bowl cereal, right?
Just anything.
You're a born marketer.
And then find a lunch
that you can like gravitate to,
like in that ice box right now,
I have got a sweet potato, right?
I've got frozen rice.
I've got a can of black beans, I got some salsa.
I'll just throw that together.
I always have some green leafies during the day,
preferably twice a day.
But my favorite dinner is always,
and we had last night rice and beans extravaganza,
just brown rice, Pinto beans, white beans, you name it.
And then I do a veggie relish on top
where it is sliced tomatoes, sliced up bell peppers,
a little bit of avocado, water, chestnuts,
little bit of tofu.
This lifestyle, I tell people,
this is the cheapest easiest way to eat
once you kind of get over yourself
and all the obstacles
that you're putting in front of yourself.
Again, I'm just gonna repeat really quickly.
Oatmeal, potatoes, rice and beans.
This is peasant food and it can be absolutely delicious
depending upon what you put on top of it.
I love putting Saracha
on a lot of my--
We go through
so many bottles of that stuff.
And then I'll go back to the community,
it's really important that you plug into a community
and you're getting support through a community
and we've got all kinds of free stuff,
community.plantstrong.com
with 25,000 people that are super active and engaged.
That just will be very welcoming and open you
or welcome you with open arms.
We've actually re-engaged
with our medical immersion programs.
So we did our first one in two years
because of COVID back in Sedona two weeks ago.
And we had 80 participants.
We had the whole plan strong crew that was there.
We had Dr. Michael clapper.
We had a guy named Dr. Brian Asbill
who's a rising cardiologists.
I don't know him.
He's a new guy on the block, he's amazing.
We had, of course my sister, my brother-in-law,
my parents did not make it to this one with,
with COVID and everything like that.
But we made sure it was safe when we,
everybody had to bring a test result
that they tested negative.
And so that was fantastic.
We're doing another one of those in Black Mountain
outside of Asheville, North Carolina in early March.
If anybody's interested in learning from soup to nuts
about the lifestyle, and we do,
Rich, we have bonfires at night, we have star gazing,
we have talent show night.
It's like food camp for kids.
And you learn to like find your inner child and laugh again
and have so much fun.
And I'm gonna deviate just for a sec
because something really powerful happened in Sedona
and I wanna try it on for size with you.
So one of the things we do
whenever we have a Sedona immersion is we have a big bonfire
and the Sedona's night sky is so spectacular,
and we have this bonfire
and we got all 80 people around it in chairs and it's cold.
And we just invite people to tell ghost stories.
And we typically have like 15 people
that decide to share and almost all of them are true.
And people will say how, you know what,
when I was a little girl, this is true,
when I was a little girl,
my mother had a best friend and she was beautiful
and she was an artist and we really connected.
And I would dream about her at night
that we'd be doing things
and she would be dreaming as well about us
doing things together.
And then when we'd meet, like in person,
we talk about,
oh, it wasn't that fun when we did all this together.
So they were visiting each other in their dreams.
And she said how she she's always had this ability
to kinda really connect with people, read people,
but as she's gotten older, she's kind of lost it.
Another woman got up and talked about how she,
when she was a little girl, there was this man,
the cookie man,
because he had this freshly made cookies in a cart
and he would come by their house in the neighborhood
and she'd always buy cookies from him.
And then she had a dream one night that the cookie man died.
And she found out the next morning from her mother
that the cookie man had died.
So she somehow was able to tap into that.
And it was like story and story again and again like that
and one of the stories that I told was one of my,
one of my wife's very good friends at a young age,
developed this ability to basically visit the dead.
And it sounds kind of crazy and far out
and listeners are probably--
I'm all about this.
Keep going.
Okay.
And she said, when she was a little girl,
what happened is something happened where her father died
and she was alone and she was scared
and this woman would come visit her at night
and hold her hand.
And this is started at age six.
And this woman's gave her the ability to tap,
go beyond that veil of this physical,
in reality that we're in,
and go beyond to be able to talk to dead people.
And I know this woman and I'm fascinated with her
but she doesn't let hardly anybody know
about this skill that she has.
So anyway, so this is happening at Sedona
where we tell these ghost stories--
And Sedona being kind of like this vortex
for spiritual expansion and mystical experiences.
It's story after story after story.
And everybody's like, God, if this wasn't true
and this couple was standing there
in their robes and then I looked again and they were gone.
And we found out that in doing our research
that 70 years ago, the house burned down
and this new one went up.
I'm busy doing stuff
and I go down to the dining room at the retreat
where we're at in Sedona.
And I'm one of the last ones to go through
and I go outside and I'm looking,
and there's one person all by themselves.
And so I'm like, oh, I'm gonna go sit with this person
and make sure they're doing all right.
And so I sit down, I said, "Is somebody sitting here?"
And they're like, "No, help yourself."
And I'm like, "Oh, I don't recognize you."
And she's like, yeah, "No, I work here.
And I work on energy and meditation and spirituality."
And Rich, the next 30 minutes blew my mind
because I just peppered her with question
after question after question and she like met me there,
and I wanted to know what happens like after we die
and I told her about all these ghost stories
and wife's friends ability to talk to the dead
and all this stuff.
And she said Rip,
"We're all trying to figure it out
in these physical bodies that we're in.
And the most important relationship that you can have
in your lifetime is with yourself."
It's really with yourself.
And I can't get too specific
as it's a little too personal on some levels,
but she said that,
you pick your parents,
you pick your parents based upon the lessons
that you have to learn in this life
that you're gonna live right now.
And most of us,
most of us have come back in this physical form
or different physical forms on average 300 times.
And I'm like, wow.
And then she said,
and if you can get in touch with your complete self
in this lifetime, and it made me think of,
you gotta do the work, you gotta do the meditation.
You gotta like dive into the being
that spiritual, like just energy
and that force that's out there.
If you can tap into it, she said, you then have the ability,
Once you die, that your energy
has the ability to break through that veil
and you are now free from this lower dimension
that we're in.
I'm fascinated by all this, it blew my mind.
And now I wanna explore this, like in a big major way.
I love it.
I mean, this is like my favorite thing to talk about.
And this podcast took a turn I was not expecting.
'Cause I look at you and I'm like,
Rip is a very practical grounded individual.
He very much lives in the three-dimensional world.
And now we're talking about ghost stories
and the karmic cycle and all of that.
I just think like,
regardless of your spiritual or religious proclivities,
there's something very powerful
about understanding that we're here for a reason
and that there are lessons to be learned,
like we're here to grow.
And so, yes, we choose our parents.
What can we learn from them?
What are the obstacles that we faced?
What are the traumas that we experienced
and what is the kernel of truth
that needs to be explored through that?
And I look at my kids and I'm like, they're my teachers,
they're putting right in front of me
things that maybe I don't wanna look at in myself.
And they're here to like, teach me those things.
And all of these experiences that we have
are opportunities to go a little bit deeper inside
to mind that truth that is trying so desperately
to hide from you.
And the more that we can embrace that
and be cognizant of that journey,
I think it is just a beautiful way to live.
And she looked at me and she's like,
'cause she been there for 15 years teaching and she said,
"Yeah, Rip, I see you as the Engine 2 guy
but what I want you to know
is you're so much more than that.
And if you could take all that positive energy
that you have and everything, and really like explore,
who are you who are you Rip?
Really, who are you?
Well, if somebody were to ask me like, who is rip,
like I see you as this incredible catalyst
for positive change in others.
Like you are a change agent
and you stand in a certain set of life experiences
with a strength and with a conviction.
And with this unbridled optimism
that conducts like a frequency of energy
that gets emanated out in the world
and becomes like a magnetic field.
That's attracting people who are looking for something
just a little bit better on their own lives
and see you as a living example
of something that they perhaps aspire to.
And you're somebody who reaches out
with this like welcome open hand and says,
come on in the water's warm.
Well, I love ending every one of our
immersion programs by basically saying, listen
I want you all to know that the light will always be on
and the door will always be a jar.
So you're always welcome.
That's a good place to lay on the plane for today,
I think .
Let's go get some
PLANTSTRONG grub.
Yeah, let's do it.
I love you, man.
I appreciate all the openness and the honesty today
and the spiritual rabbit hole that we just dove down.
That's very cool, you feel okay?
It's good, you hungry?
I feel great and I can always eat.
Good.
So we're gonna go do that in the meantime,
if you wanna learn more about Rip,
the best place to do that, plantstrong.com.
And if it's not already in your local grocery store,
it's probably coming soon.
The PLANTSTRONG line of foods available nationwide.
So, by the time this thing airs,
it'll be available in Whole Foods, plantstrongfoods.com
and we'll be starting to get into like sprouts
and Wegmans and some of those,
but just keep your eye out and do me a favor.
Go into your retailer and say,
"Hey, you need to get those PLANTSTRONG foods."
There you go.
Dispatching your army,
your legions of minions out there
to seed the world with PLANTSTRONG goodness.
Seed, yes.
All right, buddy.
To be continued next time you're out in LA.
Thank you.
Peace.
Thank you, Rich.
(upbeat music)
That's it for today.
Thanks for listening.
I truly hope you enjoyed the conversation.
to learn more about today's guests,
including links and resources
related to everything discussed today,
visit the episode page at richroll.com.